hello everyone and welcome to gamespot
gameplay I'm not Kevin de Vanna word i'm
very sorry he's not here today but i am
Tomic che and i'm filling in as a
hosting duties and i'm joined by two of
the most brilliant minds in the game
spot offices we have Carolyn Pettit hi
yes how you doing Carol I'm doing good
I'm happy to be here and God help us all
with you hosting this show time show
girl thanks and we have very Marrakech
who is a video producer and has never
been on the show before welcome I'm so
much to say so much to learn so much to
add to this show you'll be great yes and
behind the controls is Benito Gonzalez
who wants to start things up with a
little rant about titanfall yeah so the
titanfall dlc came out yesterday as
maybe a few people know and uh yeah they
removed capture the flag and pilot
hunter from the pc version and that's
like the mode I primarily play and why
why did they remove the modes altogether
yeah they just did I've heard I mean I
understand that they changed I don't
play titanfall so but they changed it in
capture the flag on console like how the
ways in which you can carry the flag I
mean right that's changed in pc as well
but in so so now the only way you can
play CTF titanfall is either in a
private server or through that that at
miss matt mix mad mix and match thing I
how it's called when I finance make it
not the matchmaking though okay the
variety pack yeah the expedition variety
pack it's the only way weird PR move to
just not um even say anything about I
find that weird like it's one thing to
remove it because of technical issues or
I don't know maybe like they'd do some
bug fixing on it but to just to just not
say anything to me see my service to all
the people maybe nobody will notice if
we just defiantly take this out of here
no [ __ ] so like I was just really mad
this morning when I found no so I just
had sorry I need out glad you get that
off your chest yeah thanks for letting
me get it off mic yes sir are you gonna
do this weekend if you can't play oh go
see Godzilla like seven times yeah maybe
they're gonna room
from the from them movie theaters a
dinner at least you can still go but it
won't play right and they're just gonna
hope that you assume that you saw it and
be the end of it yep that's the best I
can do so we're gonna go on with the
rest of the things now from electronics
arts weirdly removing a mode to
Microsoft's kind of predictably kind of
weirdly removing the kinect as a
standard inclusion with the xbox one
before they were bungle together is for
five hundred dollars and starting june
ninth for four hundred dollars you can
get just the xbox one system on its own
and the kinect is no longer relevant so
the first thing that comes to mind with
this is the inclusion of the kinect
would therefore make the system more
expensive yes do you think there is any
way the Microsoft could have justified
the existence of this peripheral or do
you think the price was always going to
be a killer at the retail shelves I i
guess i can i can envision some
alternate universe in which there there
was some amazing game for for the kinect
that convinced a lot of people to you
know the day that this is something that
they really needed to have like you know
your I mean harmonics is working on
Fantasia which is a game that's going to
use Kinect pretty you know it is a
Kinect game it is connect this corridor
what that experience is I know that
Harmonix is definitely not thrilled
about they connect no longer being a
built-in part of the of the xbox one
sort of user base um but I feel like
Microsoft pushed so hard with messaging
the connect as as it as a tool for like
interacting with you know you know your
television and these kinds of things and
that's how the people I know who really
value connect like that's what Connect
is for them it's like Xbox on you know
do this do that it's all about system
yeah it's it's just part of it it's the
voice commands for their entertainment
center is what they like about it and
but I just don't know if we're we if
people care enough about that because I
don't know i mean i'm perfectly happy
with my remote
troll and is it I mean this is the thing
that you know when it was pushed up at
e3 last year or whatever that conference
was where yeah I was like there's got to
be a better way to watch television and
I made a I made a crack about it because
I thought that was kind of an absurd
thing to say and the Microsoft picked it
up and use my tweet as a promotional not
personal material because they didn't
understand that I was being completely
sarcastic Mary you do worry that you'd
like like one or two games wouldn't have
been enough to even save this the the
peripheral yeah I mean when it comes to
a console everybody always says they're
waiting to buy the consoles based on
that next big game and you haven't
really seen you know lines down the
street for a ps4 or an xbox one because
there hasn't been any like game you know
console selling games and what's more on
top of that like a peripheral selling
game that to me is just like this
additional cost that you would have to
really sell me on this amazing game for
me to want to purchase that yeah I don't
know why I'm you know I saw like last
night during the basketball game all
these ads for kinect sports rivals yep
that's being pushed really hard I don't
know do you know how that's selling at
all of each a sales it was not in the
MPD's that were released yesterday so
it's not one of the top 10 most popular
games or that also makes sense because
it's on one platform right um yeah I
mean I don't know if I guess from a
gaming standpoint right connect on xbox
360 was never accepted as like a
necessary part of the gaming experience
so I don't see Microsoft like expecting
things to be different with the xbox one
right i mean they've they've tried this
before they've kind of tested the waters
with it before right there's no reason
to expect that things were settling on a
change on the xbox one so i think that
they they I think they really were
hoping that that pushing it as you know
an integrated part of it of like an
entertainment center experience yeah was
the way to go I agree with you Carol I
think they were banking on that and they
were kind of hoping that the games would
come along I know that they were really
excited about developer interaction and
they were you know they were just
throwing out dev kits and saying and we
want to see you guys make the games and
really excited and I do think there's a
few pieces coming out there but nothing
again
that is a console seller let alone an
additional you know peripheral seller
which is truly I mean just this
additional cost that people just don't
want Kinect Sports even if even if it
was popular I just don't see it it's not
I don't think it will be something
you'll get on the top 10 I don't think
people will care about it that much and
I'm shocked that you know it took them
this long what I find interesting
personally is the mindset of their
decisions we've been kind of mulling
over why why tell us now you know why do
this and it's very interesting yeah
times that they've been releasing all
these tidbits from you know oh we're
gonna reduce the price the connect which
can be seen as bad right they do it
before e3 so we're not talking about it
and then they announced halo 5 yeah
which is this really great way to say
like oh connect sucks like Playstations
you know gonna beat you and then they're
coming back out with with halo 5 so
they're doing this on purpose they have
a really good you know people are
starting to like them again right before
e3 oh yeah this is also yesterday was
the MPD's the American sales and the
xbox one soul 111,000 so like this is
this is a good way to cushion like April
wasn't good with the future looks bright
right and and by getting announcements
like the kinect thing sort of out of the
way now it positions them to be able to
do you know to kind of correct where I
think a lot of people felt they went
wrong last year at this year's e3 which
is like to just kind of focus totally or
at least mostly on the games right and
not on these kinds of personal war kind
of things they don't really want to dive
into they don't want to be aggressive I
think they want to focus on the content
on the game yeah and I think that's I
think it was a good choice for them to
do it the way they did it because at
this stage maybe it'll be old news by
the tiny three rolls around people just
want to know what do you have to show us
yeah so we've seen Nintendo they
introduced the wii remote in 2007 and
it's kind of a dead end technology in
that it's you know they didn't carry
through with the wii u and a lot of
people were resistant to the motion
controls and sony has their own motion
controller the move which you know
there's some good games with it but it's
nobody cares right uh and now the Kinect
is also being pushed away side arm why
are people so resistant to adopting new
tech
nology well I just think that the
experiences there haven't been the
experience is out there that have made
us feel like okay this is so great that
now that now I want this to be a part of
everything going forward right like so
many games where it's a where there are
motion controls it's like oh I wish I
could just be playing this with a
traditional controller right so as long
as it's not the as long as this new
technology is not meaningfully enhancing
the experience people are not going to
embrace it you know and that's what I
mean that's why we're kind of at this
really interesting threshold moving
forward with with like virtual reality
like oculus rift and Sony's project
Morpheus and everything where you know
no some people are like this is really
gonna gonna enhance these experiences in
such a way that we will want to wear
these things on our heads and you know
just to have that more immersive
transport of experience and other people
are like there's no way it's going to be
better you know that I like that that it
will be so much better that that then
I'll want to put this thing on my head
rather than just watch out on my
television it's killer app right like
I'm no killer app for Kinect or move it
was for Wii it was to be sports that
wasn't yeah the killer so they and their
comparisons that can be drawn from wii
sports to the new oculus and Morpheus
the idea of something new with games
that were specifically designed to give
you an experience with this said
peripheral that work well exactly like
wii sports was designed perfectly it was
meant for the wiimote and people felt
like they got this package deal it was
meant to be together and it worked
really well and so there's nothing that
says people are afraid of new technology
they love that technology we was we was
like most popular gaming system for a
really long time but we've seen it we've
been there and now what they're trying
to do is they're trying to force games
that might not necessarily fit into a
you know that type of game and they're
trying to make people make games for
this profile what about I'll just work
that's not about the tickets about the
stuff that's right and it's going to
happen again I believe it'll happen
you're gonna see those issues with with
morpheus and rift as well because you
know unless you're playing you know a
game in a submarine or in space you know
in some kind
of cockpit type thing you had a really
hard time uh feeling that we've played a
demo of Zelda on the oculus and it was
sickening because you're walking around
and you don't understand and it's it's
just too far gone you have to be almost
stationary in some kind of like cockpit
environment that's mobile for it to work
so again it's limiting the games so you
know after those games come out what is
going to propel the oculus insane star
citizen so uh one of the things i think
the connected but it was like the reason
it was integrated it was smart is that
it kind of made it more mainstream
because it was not just a video game
console like it was something that
anybody could use it was so easy to just
like turn it on and navigate that way
like do you think that not having to
connect anymore makes it less mainstream
and more you know like it's more
specific audience that we're a part of
do you think that limits that now well
yeah I absolutely feel like what like so
it's so early still an Xbox one's life
cycle right I mean so the the thing that
I keep thinking back to is how the EA
the NES launched with like Rob as like a
built-in like a peripheral yeah you
could not get the NES without Rob
original know why this was now I don't
so the reason why is because when Terry
crashed the market nobody retailers did
not like video game consoles a Nintendo
said no this is not a video game console
is a toy right the toy and we saw Sony
do something similar with the
PlayStation where they said no there's
not a video game console the PlayStation
is a computer yeah which is why it's
called sony computer entertainment I
mean we've seen we've seen the
traditions but yeah yeah only gonna Rob
with it yeah and so but then like like I
mean the NES was around for you no good
what 55 years you know or more and and
after a certain point it was like it
nobody had robbed with the NES anymore
three games for it yes a gyro might and
whatever the other ones poor who cares
we don't even know right that's how
that's how folk gets that thing was
never do yeah and so uh like it's gonna
be like it was work to the point where
when I would go over to a friend's house
if they had robbed it was weird it's
like whoa you actually have the Rob
it's going to be the same way I think
with connecting the xbox one like it's
just not going to be part of what we
think of as the xbox one package or
experience it's going to be a thing yes
some people have it but does it really
get used much like hardly ever yeah just
uh just updated to games for the Rob
yeah robot the robot series gyro might
and stack up stack up oh my god thank
you for that quick brief two games I
support as much as microsoft support of
the kinect basic Saudi I mean do you
think do you think that it's plausible
the people would have bought a connect
one as like you know not as a video game
console is something more than that can
I know that like Aaron Sampson is
talking about he wants to buy an xbox
one because he can push it more to like
his wife who doesn't play games more is
like oh it's it's not just a video game
console like do you think that that is
all like because everything there's real
does anyone remember that Microsoft room
thing oh yeah yeah I wanted that yes the
thing that likes shoots out like a
holographic image from the console
itself and turns the room into like you
know the jungles of crisis or something
yeah where's that I don't know so so was
that all just the smoke there blowing up
people's butts or is that like a real
thing we're like that actually did have
mainstream appeal potential yeah I think
it was a strategy that they tried you
know and that it didn't work out as well
as they as they hoped right and now they
are kind of backpedaling on all of that
and realizing okay what's in our best
interest is to focus on games and appeal
to double dong do not feel too you know
gamers and yeah I don't want to hate
that word I but you know but I never a
lot of their market was core gamers like
when you think of young people who are
obsessed with Xbox you think of young
people who were really into halo yeah
halo and gears and for the core gamers
that probably couldn't give a [ __ ] if
they have netflix on it they wanted to
play their game and they wanted that
experience and it I think they felt like
Microsoft had lost their way a little
bit to kind of avoid that I mean when
you look at the ad the original ad you
were talking about the house like you
know where the background changes and
they did this thing where they would
scan your skateboard and then you could
play with the escape
word that you scanned and things like
that and that then and probably not
making it either as far as I'm aware a
lot of that tech didn't get in but
nevertheless when that ad came out
people said I'm that's not really
important to me I don't need to scan my
skateboard I want to be able to play
next gen games just like I do right now
I want the same experience I have right
now with an xbox then really didn't go
that direction I think they were going
towards that home system I think I know
some people who use it I think Sean does
I think like I mean k uses the kinect
you mean yeah Kevin Kevin uses it as a
as a home entertainment hey I think I'm
can our Sean's wife does yeah like you
know he uses it to like watch movies or
stuff like that hulu and stuff like that
so it does it does have a function I
think um I don't think it's necessary
okay so one last question then we'll
move on another topic now that Microsoft
is backtracked on like everything that
made the xbox one unique yeah what do
you think their vision is of this system
interesting to me it seems like the
vision becomes go you know go back to
what the to what made the 360 work that
kind of appeal again for like hardcore
gamers people who are into shooters like
halo and gears and those kinds of things
like like have that as the base and
maybe you know do things occasionally to
try to reach out to other groups and
pull them in a little bit but but you
know really rely on and stay focused on
that base of you know what what might be
referred to as hardcore gamers okay I
agree I think they're going to be
pushing more towards games I think we're
going to see that at e3 this year I
anticipate not just that they're showing
games that they're going to be
announcing the production of games that
are going to blow people away because
that's where they're really going to
make up steam and that's where we're
going to see you next year I mean the
last year at e3 it was console console
console they were doing was talking
about the consoles this year it's going
to be game focused and everything is
going to be pitted up against which
games are better for exclusives so
they're going to be pushing exclusives
and I think that's what's really going
to make them that's the I think that's
why they made these announcements before
e3 you don't announce that halo 5 is
coming before e3 unless you have some
really good stuff coming up at e3 that's
the only way they would do that yeah as
a very good point ok so we're we're not
gonna take a quick break and we come
back we'll talk about something
completely different I'm pretty sure my
hips have never done that voluntarily
glad that you got the if you're only
listening on podcast that was Sean
dancing so you should probably download
the video version of this back from 2011
I know amazing it's okay here's another
big topic this week that really
interested me Ubisoft in their financial
reports yesterday announced that far cry
4 is coming out this year this November
for every system known to man except for
the wii u yeah um and they've had a
promotional piece of artwork that um I
don't ok so we're going to show we're
gonna show they all work but it shows a
man in a throne with a purple shirt and
he's got a like a so yeah I don't know
if you wanted to cry I mean I don't this
is a this is a complicated issue right
man betty down the fort I bombings and
he seems to be like subjugating another
man who is of a different ethnicity like
so we know it's in the Himalayas yeah
right so the man who's being kind of
subjugated there is perhaps a native of
that region and he's like holding a
grenade in his hand right so clearly
this guy in the purple suit is is
exerting power over this other guy he's
sitting on he's basically using as a
throne like a destroyed you know statue
of Buddha so you know there's a lot
there's a lot going on in the image you
know Mary yeah what does this picture
express to you it is like your
instinctual what does it communicate to
you personally Wow um well I appreciate
you starting with me I know
I'm sure carol has a lot to say about it
to me I mean I think it's so early to
tell you know there's a really good
chance you don't even know what you're
playing as yet I mean you could be that
guy with the grenade that kind of kind
of rises from the nothing to kind of
stop this man and that dude could be uh
he could just be a nice guy and we just
don't know it yet it might be yeah he's
just a man by his purple suit Carol what
do you think Ubisoft intention was with
this video what do you what do you think
they're trying to elicit in people well
I mean I think you know we there was a
conversation earlier today in the office
with like John Carlo bonini and stuff
about this and I think you know he was
right to say that Ubisoft knew that this
image would get people talking and
that's what they want it right and so
you know I think that it's you know
smart for them to put out this image now
and get you know get the get people
talking about about it speculating about
it like what did what does this tell us
about the game all these kinds of things
um cuz in reality if they would have
announced far cry 4 without any without
this picture yeah we would have said I
like far cry 3 i'm looking forward to
this or I didn't like that I don't care
about this and other than the extent of
the conversation but now we're at like
you and I are talking about yeah and so
I mean part of the issue too is I mean
you know it is a far cry game a lot of
people feel that far cry 3 was pretty
problematic in its subject matter right
i mean you played as this white dude who
kind of you know helps these people of
color you know overthrow oppression and
things like this right and like that's a
narrative that's been told an awful lot
throughout throughout you know Western
media and entertainment and it's kind of
problematic and so it's it's sort of
like okay well we you know far cry as a
series doesn't have the best track
record for like dealing with these
issues sensitively and so I like i don't
i don't think i I don't I think it's you
know too soon we don't know anything
about what about the games
narrative right um so I I guess I just
like for me when I look at discussions
around this the only the perspective
that I really have a problem with which
is one that keeps coming up is is you
know it's ridiculous to even have any
concerns about this or to think that
this might be racist or troubling it's a
video game blah blah or whatever and
it's like you know video games matter
they communicate things about the world
we live in it's ok to have thoughts that
this might be kind of problematic or
troubling like like so for me I mean I'm
not saying there's nothing set in stone
yet I don't I mean I feel like
everything is still open but but but
you're already anticipating that it is
going to be problematic you're assuming
that a white dude and stubble is going
to save that man from that evil purple
suit no I'm no I mean that's what I I
have no idea who you're gonna play as
and I'm just saying that it's okay to
suspect that the game might end up right
problematic you're you're already kind
of but on that train though what you say
well I mean of course you can correct
because video I mean because video games
have given me a reason to think that
there are that they might go might not
handle that they might not handle these
kinds of subjects with the UH the
responsibility and the sensitivity and
the intelligence that these that these
things deserve right i mean that's kind
of what i want to know do video games or
ubisoft specifically have they earned
the benefit of the doubt and using
controversial image or or do we or
should be like immediately reactionary
well question anything like this see
again like i don't think it's to say
like this image suggests that this game
might be troubling is not the same as
saying like you know rage i'm going to
be angry about this forever it's just
talking about the possibilities of what
this image is communicating and how that
might when Debbie troubling if this was
like if and director that you really
appreciate it like so who did the
credibility to get the kite ability yeah
if you saw if you saw like a director
that you really really sure like you
would probably give the benefit of the
doubt do you think reims in general have
earned the benefit of the doubt at this
point that we should be more lenient and
tolerant of this or do you think it is
totally
fair to say i have an immediate issue
with talking about a whole medium though
yeah I don't know I totally I now give
an entire mediating problem I mean I do
that I think that each game should be
judged on its own merits and when far
cry 4 comes out I think that we should
look at the game for what it is on its
own terms and what it says and all of
that but I all but I also think that yes
the games in general again typically or
very often you know send troubling
messages about these about the world
that we live in and that it's and that
it's okay to talk about that it's okay
to criticize them when they do that it's
okay to kick to think that it that it's
a problem when games games deal with
these issues irresponsibly alright and
so yeah I mean my fear is when you
release an image like this then the
topic of discussion will be the moral
implications of it the world views of it
and when the game comes out there's so
many more things besides who you play as
mmm and the story there's sure a lot too
far cry games that are ya getting
excited about Emily I wonder I assume
that this was mostly just like piece at
a marketing ploy really well timed to
get us to discuss far cry huh not just
say a far cry is coming out but there's
a lot more that will make a game good
and yeah even if it you can have a great
right you can have a great experience
even when you know the character doesn't
really push boundary is absolutely right
i mean in it and you can love games that
have an acknowledged that they're kind
of f'd up in some ways right you like
it's okay see that's the other area that
a lot of people struggle with is that
they when they like a thing you know
like if you say well yeah you know it
has this problem it's a little racist
but it's also super fun people feel they
get defensive and they feel like you're
attacking saying that they're a bad
person or whatever and it's like it's
okay to like it it took it like far cry
3 is a super fun game right it's like
the world is beautiful it's the shooting
feels good the mechanics are great like
the way that you can interact with the
bases and you know use animals
had to take out bad guys and all these
systems for like progressing and
building up your skills and the squirrel
suit you know it's it's a super super
super fun game it doesn't take anything
away from that aspect of it great for a
person to say you know it's maybe it's
kind of racist to you know I mean it's
it can be both games can be games are
multifaceted and we can appreciate them
or think about them critically on
multiple levels and we should I think
because if we you know if we want to
think that games are a medium that's
worthy of being talked about in the same
sort of sphere as things like film and
novels and stuff which you know in those
things we think about them from every
level and we talk about them when when
we find them troubling and so on and so
forth like we have to acknowledge that
that this stuff matters in games just
like it does in in any other medium yeah
um so I I don't want to judge far cry 3
story cuz I don't know its money yeah
but no matter how it turned out in your
eyes it wanted to accomplish something
yeah I wanted to say some absolutely so
I guess that brings me back to triple-a
games by and large this is a
generalization but it's by and large
they want to be fun sharp um is it
difficult to make a point story-wise
when the mechanics are all geared
towards let's have fun I don't have you
ever thought about this married dude but
do you think that those ideas clash it
all no I think you can absolutely
accomplish both I think you can appeal
to emotion I think you can appeal to
sense of self and values in addition to
having a great mechanic I mean this is a
silly example but I'm on the spot and
gears of war 3 which is an absolute
silly game actually all the gears of war
series are really silly they're meant to
be super fun they're not meant to be
taken seriously like made me really sad
because of a love story that was in it
um between domin and Marcus dang it
sorry you're a regular point I'm sorry
yeah why don't
these shoes cuz you Tom yeah I get that
a lot now like they they appeal to love
and heart and in a time of war which i
think is actually really interesting the
idea of having post-traumatic stress
disorder of having shock of war and then
still being able to love and care and
move on of brotherhood and camaraderie
and I actually really connected with
that game because of that and I don't
know if they were really trying to
accomplish that I don't think anyone
looks at gears Warren says wow what a
powerful series that was for story but
it got me and I think if you know a game
like that can can hit me you will have
games on any level of triple-a that can
really appeal to people in their values
in addition to having an amazing core
mechanic I think it's absolutely
possible i think it happens all the time
and I think that's why I think we just
love them someone Wow yeah I mean I her
on the spot more off yes yeah she's
great um as for me it for me it depends
on I guess the kind of the kind of
message or whatever the game is trying
to send right like I don't think you can
have a game that's anti violence or anti
war which in which the shooting is meant
to feel good and be fine what about uh
uh Miami that game mechanically is is
kind of brilliant it's super super fun
and it does have this point it is trying
to make as well that is it's it's
troubling yeah I I don't I I don't think
it I don't think so I mean you yeah you
after you complete the level you see all
this blood around you and these you know
the effects of your actions but you know
that when you're in it in the you know
the music is just so good and the action
is just so intense and you're just like
just trying it again and again and again
until you get in and so satisfying for
me the gameplay but then the the
adrenaline rush of the gameplay
overwhelms any sort of oh my god you're
the violence you're committing is so
wrong and horrifying message at the game
might be trying said I'll take devil's
advocate approach on this one I imagine
and I've never killed anyone but I
imagine that if you if
our soldier war and killing anyone ever
and I imagine there's a lot of injected
before adrenaline I imagine that is also
viscerally satisfying if you do what you
like if you kill someone you need to
kill like a soldier would have to and I
imagine you can also after the fact look
back like they do on Miami any troubled
by what sure yeah but i think it's i
think that it's just so different talk
about the real life experience of that
versus no yeah a game you know that's at
the end of day is trying to be is trying
to be enjoyable okay I mean anyone can
at least relate to the idea of maybe
losing your temper or getting angry and
kind of venting it out and then maybe a
few hours later days or whatever and
heels back neo like proudly I really
overreacted and I had that experience
and I played hotline Miami when I was
really into finishing level so I was
having trouble beating it so I was
getting really angry plus the music plus
you know how I wanted to do it I
actually remember specifically not
choosing a weapon and using my fists
because I was angry because I wanted to
beat it and I punched this dude to death
and then the music changed right and I
reflected immediately that I had become
a very angry person so angry in my real
life that I wanted to her murder a
person with my mitts because yeah
because that was how I was venting and
it did make me self reflect that in that
heat of the moment and you can really
lose yourself and then and then regret I
don't know how much real world sway that
has on me I'm probably just as likely to
kill someone now as before I played it
um which is high sixty percent chance
and we'll see how it goes but you know I
I think it did it did make me reflect
personally and that was even before it
was it kind of like a debated topic I
remember catching myself thinking wow I
got to into that like I was I was into
it but I also remember him bioshock
infinite having the i couldn't relate to
my character because even though they
were know it were racist and they were
kind of jerks about it and sure they
like tried to kill me once I didn't know
Stan when I was murdering so many people
um that I had just never met and I was
robbing everyone I could see and I was
becoming a really bad person and I
didn't really like myself and to a
degree um it didn't didn't drive me to
wanna be this person which is different
than hotline miami i still like enjoyed
the game and feel like I was and I lost
myself in that game but in BioShock I
was trying to finish this game and
really complete this awesome story at
the same time I I really disliked me and
it I don't know I didn't really get the
connection yeah that was actually the
last questions you bruh have a related
question though slightly other question
what did you guys do in the no Russian
part in club duty I didn't shoot anyone
uh yes a call duty modern warfare 2 I
mean there's it was the scene where
you're in an airport and you're with the
Russian Eric I said don't shoot it or
don't say anything Russian now right now
to speak yeah you can't speak Russian
but yeah you can shoot everyone all the
civilians I did not do that cuz I was
yeah I didn't shoot anybody either I
could I didn't do that yeah shoot
anybody I mean see that but it I know I
did I could shoot people right even that
in that game because I understood that
they're not real people and it doesn't
yeah you know that I wasn't taking out
my role playing the game I don't like
you are this character right my shot I
shot everyone I I kind of do I separate
myself almost similar to like when a
movie gets too sad and the kids like
I'll take my dog out back and shoot him
you know I immediately look at the TV
hang up it's a movie it's all right when
a movie when a video game gets too real
I take a step back and shoot everybody
and laugh about it which probably why
was able to enjoy bioshock infinite
because i just thought that's a game and
you know it's colorful and beautiful and
hell it's fun and I really enjoyed it I
didn't like me though okay well we're
gonna we're gonna wrap it up there we're
gonna take one more quick break and then
come back for our last segment where is
this uh tears Tom and his
dancing on a pier more come on more hip
wiggle the halfway house a little
tougher to do you play with yourself
haha
haha
I was really embarrassing nice moves Tom
that was really embarrassing we're gonna
forget that ever happened more Clips
like that on gamespot com and i've been
making gifts of them so i can put one up
after the stream if anyone's interested
thank you Mary so the last thing we're
going to talk about today is super time
force this is a xbox 360 xbox one game
yeah side-scrolling shooter where when
you die you can rewind time and then
play again from the past with on their
character and you kind of team up with
yourself over and over and over and over
again so the most you review this game
at eight yeah so the most interesting
thing for me is that um usually with
games you don't have more than one life
this game you have more than one life so
it kind of breaks game design
conventions in that way and that you can
kind of flood the screen with yourself
with yourself yeah so do you think it
successfully did that or do you think it
took shortcuts around that breaking what
we know about game designs well i guess
i mean it's what's interesting to me
about the game is that I feel like to in
order to incentivize you to rely on the
on the thing that makes this game
different the time manipulation mechanic
in a way it it almost has to be a
somewhat poorly designed run and gun
shooter right because if it were a
well-designed run and gun shooter you
could with enough skill she just like
get through it like on 11 life and not
ever really need to do that but it's
it's almost it's designed to kind of
cheaply kill you or to make you die I
think yeah I think cell design right in
the level design yeah yeah I didn't I
don't think that I experienced I'm
immediately and argue with you I didn't
think I experienced many cheap deaths I
think that the clock yeah is what for
because you have like a minute to be
Deshazier the clock is what kind of
forced me to rewind a lot of the time to
be but I thought that the actual show
okay I know the actual enemy placement
stuff was was pretty easy so you think
you could kind of you know contra style
or whatever you know run through these
stages beyond on one life yeah I
actually yeah actually do you think that
would not have to be that difficult able
to finish the boss on one life now no
people because of the time constraints I
think more than anything is I think that
I think it's actually a very simple
shooter
yeah I think it's I mean I just think
it's designed in some ways to make you
at least at some points not aware of the
hazards that are coming at you or you
know to not clearly see like where like
where enemies are going to be and where
their shots or whatever coming from so
you're more likely to die and then and
then rewind and then knowing what you
know from having just died you know try
to play differently to to respond to the
threat that you know killed you the last
time I mean Mary you played this on a
live stream with Eric T earlier this
week so what was the biggest like
surprise of love when you played this
game that like you didn't expect I was
learning everything from scratch I had
never even played it and looked at it
really before we played it on a live
stream so catching everything and I was
reading me how to play before I started
and it said kill everything so I figured
I should really try to like kill
everything like it said and that is damn
impossible in the time constraints that
you're given within the first round it
took me a long time to realize that
really my goal wasn't to you know
thoughtfully kill everything and figure
it out my goal is to run past as many
bad guys good until they swarmed me and
I had bees everywhere and then I would
reverse time and use several of the
members to kind of take out different
spots so it got a little deeper later on
once once I started to pick up on those
mechanics the idea that um you've
enemies to your left right up and below
you split yourself four times and you
take out these people I liked that that
I was starting to kind of use my wits a
little bit more than this typical run
and gun which it was in the very
beginning I was just running through as
much as I could which I didn't like and
I actually didn't find that interesting
but when i started to strategize and
that was cool but then i got too smart
and I realized I could just duplicate
myself 30 times the same person as long
as you don't die you can duplicate them
as many times as you want and then if if
I did that and we each shot boss all I
had to do is reverse time 30 times boss
once and eventually where the boss down
in one second now that's cool to figure
out that a holla moment to me was quite
brilliant I actually don't know if I
would find that interesting ever doing
it again yeah arrow point is on the
review and I have the same experience do
you think it does it matter if a game is
exploitable if it's fun and inventive or
do you think that is a problem because
this game is exploitable well if it's
fun I don't think it's a problem at all
but yeah I didn't find it fun in those
times during boss fights where I felt
like I was just I was spending more time
just rewinding and layering more
characters into the environment to
eliminate the bosses health within the
allotted time than I was actually like
the the fun part which is kind of
fighting the boss you know that is so I
feel like like the mechanic usually made
the game more interesting and enjoyable
but that was it that was an area where
it it I felt actually got in the way a
little bit and where I would have felt
like the boss fights were more rewarding
if it was more kind of my skill as a
player you know avoiding its attacks you
know hitting weak points or whatever
like you do in a typical boss fight
versus just like no I'm just going to
rewind and put another Jean Renoir hey
everyone go right about that but um I
also think this is a game that asks us
for multiple playthroughs we're sure
they want you to be creative like it's
just about being creative already on how
you do it like I want to use these four
guys in this way I think that's I think
that's what they were going for yeah and
i agree i mean-- with that i think that
the abilities of the characters if you a
lot of flexibility in terms of how you
approach you know boss fights in other
situations hmm I don't think it's I
think it's important though that the
game kind of allows you and leads into
that as opposed to just like letting the
person who's playing bae i'm gonna
challenge myself by only using block e
block Orson like why don't you make me
have that challenge why doesn't the game
give me that like I wanted more um I
wanted more situations where the game
and you've played this you can tell me
all the way you can tell me if there's
this comes up later but when the levels
I played there was never a lot of times
when it required based on having bad
guys in very particular areas that i
knew in this situation will need the
range over here i'll need the shotgun
over here and only
rocky over here yeah the only time is
wha Amy can shoot through walls that's
the only time it demands that I want to
ask a more general indie question uh cuz
I saw a lot comments say like others
looks like a super nintendo game and it
does do you think any developers lean
too much on the old-school aesthetic I
think we're getting to that point yes I
think we're getting to the point where
we're pixel the retro pixel aesthetic is
maybe becoming a little overdone it
really helps with development costs
though right there must be way cheaper
they're not doing it just because it's
cool like sure you're limited way having
three people on the team so is it
significantly cheaper to make something
like that then uh yeah what was it watch
dogs no no no I'm not talking about cuz
like transistor forensics does not have
an old tool does not look like an old
swing sister is not an indie team and I
think they need to be really clear here
that when you're when you're defining a
game and saying why can't you just have
like sweet stylized graphics like limbo
that limbo wasn't an indie game that
you're talking about studios of upwards
of seventy five people way way way way
was made by a large team the witness the
witness was made by eight people which
was shocking to me cuz i was talking to
uh to Jonathan Blow about that and I did
not realize like you can do really good
interesting looking games that are not
do you know how much the witness cost to
make no that's a that's a fortune I'm
just I'm just I'm just saying I'm just I
actually don't know the logistics behind
them because in the circle of game
design if you don't have people but you
have four million dollars you can
actually make really good graphics but
that doesn't count either so I mean I
would challenge you guys to to find that
I mean there are games out there that
have more stylized graphics but it makes
it harder and it's rare and a lot of the
times when people are comparing indie
games saying I'm so sick of pixel art
they're not actually talking about small
design teacher and I'm not criticizing
it at all as like a practical choice or
like a like a choice made for financial
reasons I'm just saying purely like yes
as something that it's not going to
continue to be like appealing in that oh
oh it's
retro you know it's charming inherently
because it's pixelated like as a
creative choice indefinitely I think
that's fair and you know I also kind of
get bored of seeing it like that's a
fair thing to do you can find ways
around that like you know for example
Thomas was alone super simple but they
found a way to kind of make you not pay
attention to the city they made the
simplicity part of the overall concept
of the game it's just really smart how
many times can you do that before that
gets all you know I mean they are
getting pushed outside of that that
comfort zone but again you have limited
time limited resources and an extremely
limited budget yeah I I actually have
not grown tired of it at all I know you
guys were all wondering like hahaha I
like the retro aesthetic so the 11 other
point that came up to me with this so
mario kart is coming out in a couple
weeks and it's amazing i love it and
this game just came out and it's just on
two systems like how do you feel when
great games are so limited and who can
actually play them uh well i can play
them uh no no it's so I it's okay with
me okay I'm different because of what
gifts I've been given in life yeah yeah
very own my privilege means that i do
not have to have to concern myself with
this problem but dude but you do see
because if it's a multiplayer game then
you need other people there well that's
true not sure so like for me um olly
olly came out in January it was a Vita
exclusive it's one of my favorite games
of the year so far and as everybody
knows i love the vita more than i love
just about anything the world's and i
was really disappointed that it was a
vida exclusive I wanted everyone to play
and now he's coming to the PlayStation
in pc but at the time I was really upset
about that and mario kart is a similar
thing we're like this game is amazing
and not many people are gonna play it so
I'm actually disappointed that it's
going to have such a limited like you
know such limited appeal ultimately so I
don't know if anyone else feels this way
that I do that I wish Playstation and PC
people were playing super time force
yeah well of course when I when a game
is good you know I want it to be
financially successful I want people who
made it
to be rewarded I want them to be able to
continue making games and hopefully
doing interesting and good work so so
yes of course I'm concerned in the sense
that it limits how successful the game
can be for the people who made it and
how many people it can reach yeah I mean
we always say if you have a complaint
Tom you should have a solution and it is
your solution that mario kart will just
be I know box and PlayStation mario
karts obviously difficult one because
that's that's good exclusive the last of
us have a limited thing as it was it was
exclusive but yeah I mean super time
force I wish it was other places and
transistors ps4 and PC and it's like you
know I and it's and I understand
completely like the witness is on going
to be on two platforms at first because
it's eight people and they can't put it
on Wii U and X bone and everything else
but I guess I always I always feel sad
when that happens because I just want
everybody who is vaguely interested to
have the opportunity to play it
something i never understood was why
xbox exclusives weren't on windows
that's all Microsoft platforms like I
don't get why they separate that well
it's the competition isn't it but
they're all Microsoft they because they
want people to buy the next boxes yes
they're fully aware of what they're
doing I mean they want you to want to
play with your friends and they want you
to feel bad about it and they want you
to buy and spend money on where's my
where's my windows xbox one
cross-platform play where's that stuff
oh that is so great wouldn't it come on
this is a really nice utopian world that
you've constructed it's all Microsoft
it's all Microsoft I mean yeah I mean
these are all great wants but I know I
just need to change about I just felt
sad so I have one last question before
we got out of here all right the two
super time force is all like you travel
back in the past or very dumb reason I
want to find and steal the Holy Grail to
keep a dumb chain of medieval time stuff
yeah dinner dinner and tournament
restaurants yeah yeah in business so if
you could go back in time and change one
thing in the history of gaming yeah what
would it be I would go back and make it
so that Nintendo had never stopped
packaging Rob with the NES
really yes like truly never back down on
that they stuck to their guns or like
people will people must see the value of
Rob the robotic operating buddy just
because i want it i would like to see
just like how that would have impacted
in ten like how like would they would
have impacted well cuz then so then like
connect supa have you know for the 360
and the xbox one maybe it would have
been like a rob 2.0 with this is ness
and we you know maybe it would have
liked his his optical sensors would have
been a little bit better and more
responsive than those on the first Rob
and they would have liked pushed this
pretty hard like oh it's much better Rob
than the last generations rob the
terrible connect on the Rob's eyes right
yeah you know I mean maybe so you know
but maybe amazing technological advances
in in like demonic we'd still maybe they
would still be playing games with robots
today you know if the Rob if Nintendo
had only believed in it enough to make
it take off and to make it work you know
at one moment that is crazy Benito you
do you have a what if that you would
love to do uh what if from a like in the
past but I'd like to change yes I wish
they kept making super nice games we
have to change something Oh Jason the
packets that's totally fine yeah and I
wish they did the cd-rom from her for
the super Ness like the dolphin which
was the PlayStation 1 I wanted that So
You you I wish Nintendo had stayed as
good and bad asses they always so you
wish they would have actually gone
through with releasing the original
PlayStation yes for the Super Nintendo
yes so how would that change things if
it happened no more PlayStation right
Sony's out of the game yeah probably no
more Microsoft and I would just be
Nintendo vs pc right like most likely
and we would have awesome games on PC
Wow okay right like I don't know I don't
know I mean I think a pc is a way more
open i'm a pc masterrace kind of guy so
you know i'm bias racist chants ringing
no no Mary what is what would you take
our way I'm son is good I don't like my
thought was like I would just go back in
time and keep stepping on bugs and
butterflies in the dinosaur era hoping
that at some point some
the president would change and the Last
Guardian would be our anus I feel like
it's possible we could have stopped like
I don't know um I'm gonna mess this up
but like meto wayda from leaving and I
think being a freelancer you know he's
not as I don't believe he's probably not
as involved or it's becoming more
difficult I challenge whether the game
is fully still coming out in production
and I just wanted him to really see it
through so this is pretty story bugs
that have got I blame the dinosaurs as
most people do for present-day issues
and I would have brought maybe the
asteroid in like a few minutes earlier
see how it pans out so that's my plan uh
so I do have a Kickstarter if anybody
wants to donate get that game out yeah
so my one which I have been holding on
to for too long is I wish that perfect
dark instead of coming out in May of
2000 for the n64 would have been
november 2001 for the launch of the
gamecube and then it would have it would
have competed head-to-head with halo
which was unknown at that point from the
developer of gold and I so all of a
sudden halos not as important and also
perfect dark it had counter ops mode
which was amazing and it had bots which
is saying that we haven't had in
shooters so maybe it would have
continued that trend as opposed to halos
online trends and then all of a sudden
Nintendo would have been seen as a more
formidable competitor because they had a
hardcore shooter on the Gamecube so all
of a sudden they would have they would
have been relevant and we might not have
seen the wii because they were so good
with the traditional consoles they might
not have sold microsoft rare because
they needed rare to make games and all
of a sudden with mom you have a lot of
stuff always comes back to rare tom at
all everything is about rare for you so
I I actually did want to write about
this I've been thinking about this for a
long time yeah that's a way better one
than mine makes me when
10 go back in time Mary and then the 40
podcast I go hold on to sonics so that
the series would never go down the
pooper no no everything started in the
pooper so next time you're wrong tom
next time you're on the show we're gonna
ask you again for another one okay we'll
put you on the spot cuz today what today
was tough but thank you thanks to Ricky
I mean your first appearance I thought
was great they did it did you did thank
you very much uh Cairo yes you were
great as always ah thanks Tom you were
great too and Benito it wouldn't have
worked at all literally without you
thank you and thank you everyone for
watching next week hopefully Kevin Van
Horn's back have a good weekend